a very good evening the prime minister
is still facing questions over his
decision to continue to support sir
Gavin Williamson as the cabinet minister
faces a series of bullying allegations
and tonight we've heard from the Civil
Servant who alleges that sagavan told
him to Slit your throat while he was
defense secretary well let's talk to our
political editor Beth Rigby SOA Beth
what have you learned
well done
um as I understand it tonight that
former civil servant who alleges that
Gavin Williamson whilst defense
secretary told this person to Slit your
throat and throw yourself out of the
window has formally reported this
Behavior to the Parliamentary Watchdog
so this is now the second formal
complaint as we understand it when the
Morton the former Chief whip has issued
a complaint into this parliamentary
Watchdog today as I understand it the
former scene former senior civil servant
has done the same uh the figure wants to
remain anonymous but has issued a
statement which we have been handed seen
by Sky News which says in a statement he
says I have made the decision to
formally report Gavin Williamson's
Behavior while at the ministry of
Defense to the parliament's independent
complaints and grievance scheme they go
on to say this is an incredibly
difficult period it was an incredible
very difficult period for me Gavin
Williamson's words and actions had an
extreme impact on my mental health the
figure goes on to say government
ministers have a code of conduct that
they are required to follow any form of
abuse is unacceptable and they finish
the statement saying I've decided to
come forward after feeling stronger
given the message given the passage of
time and after seeing the nature of his
messages to Wendy Morton now Diamond I
should say that Gavin Williamson has
denied that he bullied the civil servant
and said he had a good work in
relationships with officials in a
statement that he has released this I
should say was released before the
independent complaints was was submitted
uh Gavin William said I strongly reject
this allegation of enjoy good working
relationships with many brilliant
officials I have worked with across
government no specific allegations have
ever been brought to my attention but
sir Gavin Williamson tonight now facing
two formal complaints the Parliamentary
Watchdog and I have been told that there
could be more complaints come in indeed
even more than this so it all begs the
question Beth what is the prime
minister's attitude towards sir Gavin
going to be he's valuably supported him
so far could that change
it could change look this is a fast
moving story and we're going to have to
now see what down in streets say about
this I think that the tone of the way in
which uh the prime minister's
spokesperson defended sir Gavin
Williamson tilted a bit this afternoon
um the afternoon when they spoke to
journalists
um was asked whether the Prime Minister
might wait until any complaints
procedures have been gone through to
cast judgment over the suitability of
Sir Gavin in his government the prime
minister spokesman said this afternoon I
don't think he the Prime Minister Nestle
feels the idea would be for him to wait
until both these things have fully
concluded I should say both these things
are actually Wendy Morton's complaints
because she complained to conservative
Campaign Headquarters so the party about
Gavin Williams conduct and then
complained to the Parliamentary Watchdog
this is now then another complaint and
Rishi sooner and his team will now have
to assess those two formal complaints
his spokesperson said today obviously
the Prime Minister would active and when
he felt it was appropriate to do so but
you have to ask the question now dermit
there's two formal complaints in there's
rumors abound in Westminster that more
people could come forward we haven't had
any other uh formal
complaints at the moment but you have to
ask the question about Rishi sunak now
one former cabinet minister suggested to
me tonight this was before this came out
I should say that they thought that the
Prime Minister would want to hold on to
Gavin William not since because getting
rid of him so quickly after he appointed
him having been informed that there was
a bullying complaint against him but now
getting rid of him that about turn might
look like it undermines the prime
minister's judgments so soon into office
but I have to say this now looks like an
open wound and it's hard to see how the
party cauterize it if more MPS and more
former officials come forward and make
complaints okay Beth many thanks for
breaking that and explaining it let's
see what develops now Beth would be our
political editor there